[Music]
I just missed being on my couch with my
mom and my daddy watching a movie after
dinner and playing with my dolls kind of
miss the simplicity of home
I really really loved what you said in
your package tonight about like just
you've been thrust into this and there's
like no place better than your mom's
couch when she just treats you like a
normal person and you're not like People
magazine cover girl like you're just
Hannah yeah I like good like put myself
in that place of our really great grave
section l-shaped sectional and just in
the corner seat with my dog in my lap I
just I can't wait to to get to do that
one day soon but it's hard when I feel
the support and I feel the love but
there's nothing like being home and
trying to navigate this new life on my
own in LA has been really challenging
I'm so great I'm so grateful and I never
want to seem like I'm not but it is it
but it also has been so crazy how this
all happened for me I never did this for
fame or whatever this is
I just I'm still a normal person just
with everybody else watching the ride
and thinking it's one thing when it's
not it's a multi like I'm a I feel like
I'm a complicated person so I've got a
lot of different emotions going on she's
a normal person with a lot of
rhinestones
[Music]
this is the week I'm going to rename
this week of dancing stars crying with
the stars because you're either crying
on the floor crying with the family
crying at a window like you like
everyone is crying this window was so
easy to cry no I was missing my mama but
also retired so it is getting emotional
because we are one big family and and
now is the time where people are gonna
be going home and you know everyone
cherishes being here and you don't want
to go home so it gets emotional when
someone your friend goes home and there
was a moment tonight when you guys are
up though there's only four couples left
and they are they shot to your faces and
you both you looked worried for the
first time I think this competition you
were looking around being like is it is
it me tonight I mean you don't know and
even though I were I've been working so
hard and putting everything into it you
never know like when that's gonna be
your time and I I would be so sad if it
came to an end because I feel like I
just have so much more to give and
that's shocking because I've been on
television before so long that you would
think I would want to be done but I
don't I don't at all like this has been
really great for me and just an
emotional experience and the best way to
grow and and and look forward to what my
life is gonna be like what do you make
of sailors super emotional goodbye me
she couldn't even speak I'm so proud of
her
hey hey hey hey you okay
[Music]
I think it was shocking I mean she she
had got amazing scores she danced she's
been dancing amazing it has grown so
much and she started his competition as
a fan watching her mom and she made it
to week six which is such a testament to
her and and Val did an incredible job
yeah and like I said it's a big family
so tonight the bottom two was shocking
because they were both at the top of the
leaderboard this weekend you know they
both gave so much and I feel like it's
really hard because everyone left is
giving their all and it's like someone
has to go home unfortunately so we're
just very thankful that we're still here
for the weekend hopefully some more
thank you guys cheers we've got more
work to do
[Music]
[Applause]